the jurogan experience
the conversation that i had yesterday
with francis ingano
about escaping cameroon making his way
to morocco
and being arrested seven times trying to
escape morocco and go to spain
because that little piece of land that's
technically europe in the north of spain
north of africa they would they would
take them after they arrested them they
would hold them
and then they would bring them to the
[ __ ] sahara desert and drop them off
and they did that to him seven times
they literally tried to kill them
they'd try to drop them off in the
desert no food no water no nothing no
clothes
they did it in the winter they did it in
the summer in the winter it's horrific
because the the temperature drops to an
insane level
and there's they have no transportation
they're nowhere to go
and these africans are doing this on a
daily basis
making this journey from whatever
country they're in in africa to try to
make it to europe
and he did it over the course of 14
months
and he outlined this 14-month journey of
homelessness
living in the forest dude it was
[ __ ] crazy crazy do you know about
eritrea which is southern ethiopia so
the only reason that came across my desk
is there was an article and it said this
is the only country where journalists
are less free than in north korea i'm
like
i'm getting the silver now and what they
did
is they took the journalists put them in
steel cages and left them in the desert
bye and it's it's
no one knows about this place what's
amazing about eritrea is they took the
journalists and put them in steel cages
and just left them bye-bye
but the capital of eritrea when
mussolini took over ethiopia it's a
perfectly preserved italian city
so there's this like fiat factory that
they convert into like a museum
so when you're in the capital asmara
you're like in
the riviera whatever some european city
and as soon as you step
out it's hell on earth holy [ __ ] so it
but
north korea overtook them took back the
lead of worst country for journalists
but
it's a fascinating country that no one
knows about and the oppression there
is absolutely insane how many
journalists have they killed
i have no idea this wasn't recently this
was a while ago and it's the only
country i think with no foreign
journalists in it
like the thing that drives me crazy and
i know you agree
is that there's so many people who like
read the new york times or the new
yorker
and they think they know everything
about the world because they just read
the same publication everybody else does
where there's so many places that are so
barbaric
like turkmenistan whatever that it
doesn't cross your desk so you don't
even think it
exists or it matters it's like well i'm
sure i would have heard of it it's like
no no it just
isn't sexy enough for someone to cover
and these people are
basically resigned to having a nightmare
existence
not that necessarily we could do
anything on an individual level and it's
just
horrible yeah there's a lot of them and
it's the
unfortunate thing is there's too many to
really follow yeah if you spent your
day today waking hours paying attention
to all the atrocities that are being
committed
in the world you would never have time
for anything else because they're
constant
like we're just we're we're just so
accustomed to this life here this first
world life
that any deviation from that at all just
seems horrific like anything that goes
wrong in america
seems like intolerable and horrific in a
human rights violation and like
this is the shining of the world and
someone like you who's an immigrant can
speak to this better than most
you and someone also who has traveled to
places like north korea who understands
the world better than most
this is going to talk about this yeah
this is the theme of my next book the
white pill which is just talking about
people don't know how bad it used to be
and how close we came this country to
falling
in some very very bad directions
uh and because it's kind of thing where
if you don't talk about it you forget
you know just what the past was people
in this country have no idea about
stalin i'm writing a lot about him or
the berlin wall
the things that they did it's just and
you hear these like i was just
i'm writing right now there was this
part what stalin would do is like he'd
kill
parents right because they were traitors
or whatever that kid who was left behind
who now lost their parents boy or girl
whatever
everyone knew if i helped that kid my
family's under suspicion
why are you helping the child of these
traders oh were you colluding with them
in the past because they're trying to
find links
so this poor kid is now a complete
social outcast
even family friends wouldn't even look
at them even the children that they were
friends with wouldn't look at them
and they'd fallen away in history no one
i mean there's so many cases like this
and
americans don't have any idea of what
that's like
how recent that was yes it's not even
100 years ago right
right not even 100 years ago people were
resorting to cannibalism with their own
children they were cannibalizing their
own children because they were starving
to death
thousands and thousands of people
starved to death like they don't even
know
an accurate number of how many people
starve to death under stalin
uh margot hunnicure who died i think in
2016
she was the head of education east
germany and she had a concentration camp
there for children which ended in
89 that's not that long ago we were
watching shows in 89 you and i
and what they would do is they would
institutionalize these kids
to make them into good communists so no
singing no humming
you know and it would be the kind of
thing where like there's there was once
one survivor she was suicidal because
her stepdad kept raping her
well you're suicidal you gotta
institutionalize you right so they put
them sometimes in solitary
and the thing is the people who were
guardians in the in this place
they would sexually assault the kids
with impunity and take them home
what else she would do is uh if parents
were
suspicious under suspicion of the state
they'd take the kids
and force good communist families to
raise them
they would take newborns and you would
never see your kids again
and your kids were discouraged from
trying to seek you it's the levels of
depravity that would happen in these
countries
we are so oblivious to in america and
it's like all right if i have to be the
one to kind of talk about this
and to we should treasure people take so
much for granted here
they don't know how bad it can get catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience